[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRITT,
"SWEET SPOT"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRITT,
"TRAVELING ALONE"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you.
Thank you.
This is a guitar I stole
from my father.
And it's been on tour for about
three months now, and he
is going to kill me.
In time.
It's retiring at Christmas.
Thank you for having me and for
being so well-behaved and
for having a kitchen
that I could raid.
I've been on tour for about
three months straight, and I
was really glad that your
cupboard was a little more
stocked than mine.
This next song is a song that
I wrote called "Spring," and
it's about--
I don't know.
Good songs are about more than
one thing, but you sort of fly
a flag and say it's
about one thing.
And this-- it's about the
life cycle of a flower.
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRITT,
"SPRING"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you.
I feel like I should tell you
funny stories about things
I've googled in my life.
But maybe we should get to
know each other a little
better first.
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRITT,
"TO MYSELF"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRIT, "SMALL
TALK RELATIONS"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIFT MERRITT: In this
next song, I was--
I guess on this whole record I
was thinking about how much
noise there is and what of it
is actually important, and
what of it is actually
just noise.
And somehow I got to thinking
about how Jesus and Robert
Johnson probably were in the
exact same position when they
were about to make these big
decisions in their life like,
I need to get born, or, I need
to sell my soul to the devil
so I can play guitar.
They probably felt very
similarly crazy and very
similarly hopeful
that they were
making the right decision.
So--
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRIT,
"STILL NOT HOME"]
[APPLAUSE]
TIFT MERRITT: Let's see.
When people are so
quiet, I'm so
compelled to tell you things.
I guess I should tell you that
when I was writing this
record, I lived fairly
close to here.
I'm originally from North
Carolina, and I moved to the
City a number of years ago--
not so long ago, but--
I live very close to the
City Winery, and--
I love this story.
I think it's such in
New York story.
One night I was there to see
some friends play, and-- or, I
don't know, I was there
doing something.
And I told them that they had
this beautiful grand piano
that I-- there's nothing--
there's very little in the world
I love as much as having
an instrument in my
hands, especially
playing a beautiful piano.
And I said, well--
they said, well, if you love
playing our piano so much, you
can come down and play
it any time you like.
And I said, you ought
to be really careful
saying that to me.
And they said, no, no, no,
really, we mean it.
And I said, no, not,
really, I mean it.
And so being a writer, being a
musician, I think you spend so
much of your time in the
landscape inside--
traveling alone--
and I was able--
going to the City Winery every
morning when I woke up to get
my cup of coffee, I would go--
and I was really a part
of their staff.
They would be getting the coffee
cups and the table
settings ready, and the wine
was being made, and things
were getting chopped
in the kitchen, and
I got to know everybody.
And I never felt so open.
I think writing is a very
personal-- it's the most
personal thing I
can do, really.
And they made me feel so
comfortable, I just was in the
corner, and my hair in a big
mess, and practically in my
pajamas, and I would play this
piano and get lost, but I
would have this beautiful
quotidian life
with everyone there.
Hey, how are you?
How are you doing
this morning?
Are you well?
And I would play for about an
hour, an hour and a half, and
then when they opened the doors
for lunch, I would kind
of walk home with whatever I had
been drifting on at that
piano in my hand, and
then I would write.
And this, in particular, was a
song that was born on that
piano, right here in
this neighborhood.
So I thought I would
play it for you.
Thank you for having me.
[MUSIC - TIFT MERRITT,
"FEELING OF BEAUTY"]
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you very
much for having me.
RITA HOUSTON: Welcome home.
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you.
RITA HOUSTON: Because you've
been traveling.
Tell us about some of your
travels, because you've been
out for a few months with the
band, and running around.
TIFT MERRITT: Yeah, I've been
out for a long time.
I'm at the point where I'm
really lonely if I'm not in a
dressing room, and
clean clothes are
totally foreign idea.
I've been on the road since
about the beginning of
September, and I've been
out with my band.
We were all around the US, and
then we were in the UK, and
then we went to Europe, and I
just got home on Friday night.
So I don't know what month
is, and I haven't
cooked in three months.
RITA HOUSTON: Yeah, that's
the weird part.
So you just got home, and then
last night and tonight we're
catching you right in the
middle of making two
appearances alongside your
friend Andrew Bird at
Riverside Church.
How was that?
TIFT MERRITT: It's so beautiful
there, and he is
such an incredible musician.
I don't know if you're
familiar with him.
And he's an incredible player,
but he's also such an
incredible singer.
He's really one of my favorite,
favorite people.
And I don't say that lightly.
You know, you sing with people,
you sing with a lot of
different people, and when
something really rings, you
go, oh, oof, wow.
So he's really one of my
favorite people to sing with.
RITA HOUSTON: Did you
guys know each other
back in North Carolina?
Like, were there any connections
back then, or--
TIFT MERRITT: Not really.
I mean, I think we crossed
paths, and I knew he was with
the Squirrel Nut Zippers.
And I think I was probably
shy, and--
so we met maybe two years ago.
We did the Cabinet of Wonders
together, and we sang
together, and I think
we both went, oh.
And then he was kind enough to
sing on this record, too.
I wrestled him into coming
and doing a duet
with me on this record.
RITA HOUSTON: Which is
beautiful, the song "Drifting
Apart," which is really nice.
Tift, so this new album is
called "Traveling Alone." And
as the title suggests, and as
many of the songs that we
heard, there is a spirit, I
think, for a lot of writers of
traveling and gaining
perspective when you leave
where you're from, and then
you can look back.
As a writer, is that a big
part, for you, of where
perspective and inspiration
comes from?
Because you almost have to leave
your world to be more of
an observer of it and
write about it.
TIFT MERRITT: I think that's
true, and in fact--
my nose is itching, so that
means that my mother can hear
whatever I say about this.
But I think that works
on two levels.
I'm from North Carolina, and
North Carolina was a very,
very particular place in time
when I was growing up.
I mean, it was very different
from any other
place in the world.
It was sort of before everyone
had a cell phone, and there
weren't any chain stores, and
you knew everyone, and
everyone knew your parents, and
everyone knew everything
wrong that you ever did.
And I like that kind
of closeness.
But I also was always
encouraged to leave.
I wasn't chained to a tree
in this small town.
And I think that's why I can
feel so fondly about it.
You know, you are encouraged
to leave your home
to find your home.
But on another level, I think
that "Traveling Alone" really
is a way to talk about the
landscape inside, to talk
about an interior life,
and a home inside.
And I'm not--
obviously, I'm a performer and
a loud mouth, and I'm not an
introvert--
but I spend a huge amount of my
life in this landscape on
the inside.
And I think that you can kind
of sound like a jerk unless
you give it a sort of
rough-hewn way--
find a way to talk about
it that is real world.
And that's what I wanted
to do on this record.
RITA HOUSTON: Do you hear things
from fans that are
meaningful to you?
Because when you write songs
of such personal nature, I
think people have a way of
internalizing them, and
putting their own stuff.
You must hear all kinds of
things from fans who like,
relate to your music.
Anything you could share?
TIFT MERRITT: I'm
trying to think.
You know, I think the nicest
thing is when people come and
tell you that your music has
meant something to them.
And must oftentimes they'll
say, well, it helped me
through a hard time.
And I don't know, I'm just
grateful for that.
I think that making work and
being a musician should really
be the reward in
and of itself.
I mean you can't--
it's not about being
a celebrity.
It's not about numbers.
It's not about making
a lot of money.
It's about making something
of meaning and beauty.
And when that resonates with
someone else, you're just
grateful that your work actually
means something to
someone beyond yourself.
RITA HOUSTON: But you're
really speaking
like a writer now.
I mean, that's really--
TIFT MERRITT: Well, I think
that I am a writer first.
I was a really crappy musician
for a long time.
Now I've just been at
it long enough that
I know how to listen.
.
RITA HOUSTON: If you guys one
start to queue up with some of
your own questions, we'll
definitely take some.
Don't be shy.
There are two mics.
So do that.
Here's a question for you.
Do you have to be a great
writer to be a great
songwriter?
Or, the reverse, do great
songwriters always make for
great writers?
Because you studied creative
writing and stuff.
So you have both of
those things.
Do you have to be a great
writer to be a great
songwriter?
TIFT MERRITT: No.
I think you have to be
honest, and I think
you have to get lucky.
And I think that those are
the two things that
I can't find myself.
But I also think that--
I think that creativity is one
of those things where, when
you start--
before your work is invented,
when you're trying to invent
this thing that isn't
invented--
you can go so many different
mediums.
So when I was starting, I really
wanted to be a writer.
I wanted to write books.
I wanted to say heavy, serious
things about life.
And I could have gone in that
direction, but I would have
needed to commit
to that medium.
And instead, I committed to this
shorter form, which is--
a good song is about
three sentences.
Four if you have a bridge.
And now, I've spent the past 15
years of my life trying to
say something in
four sentences.
And when I go back and I try
to write prose, I feel very
watered down.
I go, this is moving
way too slow.
Get to the point.
And so I think the deeper
you can commit to
your medium, the better.
RITA HOUSTON: And for you it's
about paring it down.
TIFT MERRITT: I like
the intensity of--
I like the one-two punch.
And I don't think there's
any going back.
You get used to that.
RITA HOUSTON: It's like
cooking, you know?
You've got to reduce
the sauce.
TIFT MERRITT: That's right.
Cook down those bones.
RITA HOUSTON: Exactly.
Tift, I read--
when I googled you
last night--
I read that your dad's record
collection was a big
inspiration to you.
And I'd love to hear some
stuff about that.
Because in the performance
today, there was one song that
just felt like a straight-up
kind of country tune.
And I know your record, so I
know a lot of the songs are
fleshed out with pedal
steel, and stuff.
But then when you play the tune
at the piano, that was a
straight-up soul, R&B
kind of number.
You could almost hear the horns
and the minor chords.
So I imagine--
I don't know your dad, I don't
know his record collection--
but I imagine this visual
of country albums right
alongside, like, Otis Redding.
So tell us a little
bit about that.
TIFT MERRITT: OK.
The first thing is that
my dad really
wanted to be a musician.
And somehow, I talk about him
enough that he thinks he's
super famous.
And so I call him and I go,
hey Dad, in Sweden today,
somebody yelled out that
they know they
you like to go fishing.
And he's like, oh,
that's great.
RITA HOUSTON: What fishing?
TIFT MERRITT: He just like--
fishing.
He likes to fish.
So now I'm going to have to call
him, and be like, I was
at Google today, and I talked
about you, Dad.
Oh, he's going to so glad.
So anyway, my dad taught
me how to play music.
And my dad is really why I
consider myself a folk
musician, because he played
everything by ear.
He played guitar by ear, he
played piano by ear in this
very simple, simple,
simple way.
And he definitely thought
he was a genius at it.
And it turns out
he kind of was.
And he had--
I can remember being
a child and sitting
with him on a Saturday.
And he would play Bob Dylan
songs, and play his harmonica,
and finger-pick.
And then he'd play Percy Sledge
songs on the piano, and
then we'd drive around
in the car and sing
Dolly Parton songs.
And in a lot of ways, I think
part of why I play music is
because I felt so close to
my father in those times.
Playing music with someone
is such an expression
of the best of life.
So my father really gravitated
towards a good song, and he
didn't really think about
it beyond that at all.
And I have to say that it's
really hard for me to think
about that at all beyond
that, too.
So--
RITA HOUSTON: So who are some
of the greats that you hold
high in the music world, and
then we'll ask you the same
for writers and stuff.
Who are the guys who wrote
the blueprints for you?
TIFT MERRITT: Well, Dylan.
I mean, what an innovator.
And I think Dylan, and
I think Neil Young--
Dylan for his writing,
intelligence, and the power,
and Joni Mitchell for how
expressive she is, and how
personal she is, and what
unique musical she has.
I think Carole King as a writer,
and someone who's
earthy and unselfish,
and generous.
I think she's a real
role model.
Neil Young, I think,
for just the not
intellectual side of it.
Not that he's not intellectual,
but it's all heart.
I think that if you're
songwriter it's really hard
not to go worship
at those places.
And there's a lot
of the country--
I mean, people say, oh, you're
a country singer.
And I go, I'm not mainstream
country.
But I will say that a lot of
those leading ladies-- like
Kitty Wells, and Emmylou Harris,
and Bobbie Gentry, and
Tammy Wynette, Loretta Lynn--
I think they held themselves
with a great deal of dignity.
And there was a sense of
abandon, and a sense of music,
and a sense of show,
but there's
also a sense of meaning.
And when I looked at the music
industry and tried to see
myself, and there's like Madonna
and Bob Dylan, if that
were the spectrum, where
would I fit?
And I thought, these women
held themselves with a
sincerity and a dignity that
I could relate to.
So--
RITA HOUSTON: That's
interesting.
We have a question.
Go ahead.
Give him the mic.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
First of all, I have two
questions, if that's OK.
Great performance.
Loved watching you.
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to ask the
questions and then you can
answer them both.
Are you a keyboard player that
learned to play the guitar, or
vice versa?
That's the first question.
And the second question is, how
strong is your emotional
attachment to that guitar with
the two holes at the bottom of
the bridge.
TIFT MERRITT: Oh, that's
a good question.
Well, the first thing is
that I am probably a
piano player first.
I took some lessons when I was
really little, but then my dad
showed me, and I got to the
point where you had to write
down how long you practiced
every day, and I had the moral
conundrum of lying or admitting
that I was not
practicing.
And so I stopped taking
piano lessons.
So I'm not trained like that,
but I find that I play the
piano like a melody
instruments.
I can find melody.
I can get lost in a piano for
hours and hours and hours.
I started playing guitar when
I was a teenager, and so it
wasn't like one really led the
way, but I'm probably more at
home at the piano.
Although I have really come to
pride myself on being a good
rhythm guitar player.
I consider myself part of
the rhythm section.
And I am endlessly fascinated
with how locked I can get with
the groove and how deep I can
get that pocket to go.
At first I was really ashamed
that I couldn't solo, and now
I think that it's pretty
important to be
a good rhythm player.
This is my guitar, Little Red,
and I'm really attached to it.
Somebody gave it to me-- or
sold it to me when I first
started putting out records,
because they told me that I
had this big oversized guitar
from the '70s, and they said
it made me look really short.
So I really was upset about this
guitar, because it was a
short joke to begin with.
But this guitar has been on the
road with me for 10 years,
and it's kind of a work horse.
And I play '60s Gibsons because
they have this great
warmth, sound that's great for
strumming, but they also have
really a small head stocks,
so that I-- my
hands are really small.
This other guitar is actually
my father's guitar that I
stole from him for this tour.
And he's going to kill me
because I've marked it up.
But he says that he won
it in a pool game.
I don't believe him.
So that one is actually--
I'm even more attached to that,
because he will kill me
if anything happens to it.
So, yeah.
Is that good?
Yeah, OK.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I wanted to
jump on what you said about
being a rhythm player.
I'm actually a singer-songwriter
myself, and
I've been having some trouble
with rhythm, and I was just
wondering how you got
to be so good at it.
TIFT MERRITT: Well, first of
all, it took a lot of years,
and I'm married to drummer.
And I think that things like
playing two records that you
love, like Carter family
records, where the rhythm
playing is really, really,
really important, playing to
the old country records where
the rhythm playing is really a
part of the band.
And also, practicing
with a metronome.
I mean, I have to say that
practicing is so much a part--
people think that rock and roll
is just, there are no
rules, and you drink
some whiskey and it
comes out of you.
But being a good musician is--
there's a lifetime
of study there.
And I think that practice and
listening, learning how to
listen, I feel like I just--
every day I get up and go,
god, I didn't even know I
could listen that hard.
And I think listening is
kind of a Zen thing.
You just have to practice and
listen, and know that it adds
up to something over time.
Does that make sense?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Rita, you started--
you asked about musical
and literary things.
You didn't quite get
to the literary.
And as much as having been to
the FUV Holiday Cheer concert,
and having heard Steve Earl, who
has managed to write and
play music, I was wondering if
you could list some of your
literary aspirations.
Because when you talk about
home, I find myself thinking
of Frost and the idea of, home
is the place where, when you
go there, they have
to take you in.
And of course, Wolfe saying,
you can't go home again.
And whether--
if you could list that,
I'd be very intrigued.
TIFT MERRITT: My literary
aspirations, or my influences?
AUDIENCE: Influences.
If you'd like to go into
your aspirations,
I would very much--
TIFT MERRITT: No, I was
about to say, I don't
think I have any.
Except to be a good
songwriter.
AUDIENCE: Well, your
musical gifts more
than make up for that.
TIFT MERRITT: Well,
I appreciate that.
My literary aspirations are
to be a good reader.
In the beginning,
my main literary
influence was Eudora Welty.
I think she's such a master
of the short form.
And she has such a point
of view, and
such a sense of voice.
And there were other reasons
that I loved
Eudora Welty, too.
One was that she such a
unique artist and an
innovator as a woman.
She traveled by herself, she
never married, she was a
photographer, she didn't-- she
broke a lot of rules, but she
broke them in a lovely way.
And I really loved how
multifaceted she was.
I also loved that she was from
this small southern town, and
she always lived there, and she
always looked out this one
window, and she didn't need
to leave completely.
I'm sure she had journeys, but
I think that that's such a
beautiful way to make art.
To me, that meant that she
always found so much in
humanity that she didn't have
to make up false dramas, and
she didn't have to have this
crazy life, that she could
come to that window every day
and find something of depth to
write about.
And I thought that was
really beautiful.
I'm a huge Cormac
McCarthy fan.
I think his work is so
beautiful, if sometimes so
violent that I have
to turn the page.
And Faulkner as well.
I've spent the past year really
fascinated by this
poet, Jack Gilbert, who actually
just passed away, and
who was something of a character
in his life.
And I also really, really love
Annie Dillard's nonfiction and
her writing about life
and nature and the
nature of being a writer.
The intensity there is really,
really, really beautiful.
So I'd say those are those
are my staples.
AUDIENCE: I heard-- when at
college, Eudora Welty came--
I'm a Vassar boy.
Eudora Welty came there, and she
read "A Wide Net." It was
just a lovely performance.
You know, just there, just very
calm, just-- the story
spoke for itself.
She just--
that was all she really
needed to do.
TIFT MERRITT: She seemed
like she was a
really amazing woman.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RITA HOUSTON: It's interesing
you mention the photography,
because you're a photographer
too, right?
TIFT MERRITT: Hmmmm.
RITA HOUSTON: You dabble.
TIFT MERRITT: Strong words.
I dabble.
RITA HOUSTON: You dabble.
You have a camera.
TIFT MERRITT: I'm really--
you know, I think--
RITA HOUSTON: You're more
than a dabbler.
TIFT MERRITT: Wait, hold on.
I feel like we live in this time
where we're all supposed
to be superhuman people.
Where we're supposed to be
perfect parents, and perfectly
dressed, and perfect
overachievers, and eat
perfectly, and be perfectly
skinny, and all that crap, and
I feel like there's this impulse
to for artists to
conquer other mediums.
And I don't feel that--
I think creativity doesn't fit
in a neat package, and
everything that I do creatively
points back to
being a musician and
being a songwriter.
So I'm not out to conquer
any other mediums.
I think that's important.
I like to just be myself.
I'm not a superhuman.
But I love to take photographs,
because I think
that, first of all, using your
eyes to see other people is
such an important part of being
a compassionate writer.
And you need to look outside of
yourself, and you need to
make yourself look outside
yourself, and find the beauty
and joy in these small things
that you see when you take the
time to really look
at other people.
And a camera is a really
beautiful way to do that.
And I also think that--
I'm so skeptical of how nice I'm
treated in situations like
this, and this sort of being
the center of attention.
And I think it's my job as a
writer to keep turning my
attention back.
And I think it's really
important to not rest on your
laurels and be the center
of attention.
RITA HOUSTON: You seem to have
this sort of core humility to
everything that you approach.
TIFT MERRITT: I'm a Southern
Protestant.
I do not exist.
RITA HOUSTON: But that is
a core kind of thing.
At the end of January, January
26th, I just heard about the
show you're going to be
doing at 92YTribeca.
Tell us about that, because
it's a pretty cool
collaborative kind of thing.
TIFT MERRITT: Yeah.
It's--
it stems from this--
I do a radio show for Marfa,
Texas Public Radio, which I'm
really behind on right now
because I've been on tour.
But I seek out artists, and I
talk to one artist a month
about how they really make
their work, and how they
really live their lives.
And usually these people who are
making really unique work
are making really unique
lives, too.
And people who are doing their
own thing, I think, come
across the same problems, but
they are so off doing their
own thing that they don't--
it feels more personal.
They forget that this is
a common situation.
So I ended up inviting this
painter, Anna Schuleit, to
come on my show.
And she was so beautiful.
And we were the same
age, and--
I don't know, I just felt like
I just met at a much better
version of myself.
Much more evolved.
And we--
RITA HOUSTON: And is
she from Texas?
TIFT MERRITT: No, she's here.
She's actually from Germany.
She lives here.
And we had so much in common
that we became friends, and I
adore her work.
And so, we were trying to find
a way to collaborate, and she
does these beautiful live
drawings with a
projector and light.
And she's done it with dance
performances before, and we
thought performing "Traveling
Alone" with her creating a
life drawing--
"live drawing" is what
she calls it--
would be a really
beautiful thing.
So I've never done anything
like that, but I think it
could be really, really
beautiful, emotional.
And she's a very beautiful
artist.
RITA HOUSTON: And tell
us her name again.
TIFT MERRITT: Anna Schuleit.
RITA HOUSTON: And that's January
26 at 92YTribeca.
That sounds very cool.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you, guys,
and thank you, Tift.
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you, Rita.
RITA HOUSTON: I mean,
beyond fun.
Very fun, thank you.
TIFT MERRITT: Thank you guys.